un hangar rempli de vêtements pour tous
les âges des montagnes de chaussures 2
sec ici chaque geste n'a qu'un seul but
trier pour éviter que ces texting ne
finisse à l'enfouissement de cette idée
est née titans de récup il y a
maintenant une année protéger
l'environnement tout en créant une
activité solidaire et sociale c'est
l'objectif affiché de l'association et
de ses deux gérants l'idée c'était
d'allier un petit peu les deux et de
jouer sur la protection de
l'environnement aussi donc on a trouvé
je dirais on avait quand même quelques
idées et puis le recyclage des xi
n'existant pas sur la réunion s'est dit
pourquoi pas le développer ici
localement c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis pas mal d'années en europe
depuis sa création titan grecu pas
permet la collecte de 130 tonnes de
textiles en 2000 qu'annonce le même
chiffre a été atteint en l'espace de
quatre mois grâce aux bornes de
récupération installé dans vie on est
sur des objectifs qui sont multipliées
par dix à terme ces vêtements sont
collectées à la fois au travers des
bornes que l'on met en place faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une quarantaine de
blanche qui sont positionnées sur le
département
et qui lie à une page facebook qui vous
donne accès à une cartographie ou
voiliers l'ensemble des points on les
collectes aussi au niveau des
déchetteries notamment aujourd'hui
sur les principales
intercommunalité pour sylvie responsable
de production mais aussi co gérante leur
fierté ce sont les emplois qu'ils ont pu
créer grâce à leur activité on a démarré
l'année dernière avec 14 personnes cette
année on est avec 18 personnes et on
vient d'un mode embauche un encadrant
technique et une conseillère d'insertion
socioprofessionnelle pour nous aider à
lever les freins de ces personnes en
difficulté est de les mettre dans une
situation de travail réel et l'accent
que nous mettons sur la formation de ces
personnes là c'est vraiment acquérir un
savoir être et un savoir faire
professionnel qui va leur permettre
d'augmenter leur employabilité sur le
mas indue sur le moon dans le monde du
travail des contrats ces huits cia pour
insérer des personnes en perte de
vitesse qui ont besoin d'être aidées
chaque tâche effectuée ici par chaque
employé d'un geste d'espoir à l'image de
l'est il a promu un parcours
professionnel exemplaire mais qui a dû
changer de route pour des raisons
personnelles désormais un autre projet
de vie s'offre à la jeune femme aussi
issu d'un mc s
j'ai fait une première année en bosnie
donc ensuite j'ai arrêté mes études j'ai
commencé à travailler parce que j'ai une
petite fille entre temps qui très
heureuse parce que en parallèle où j'ai
un projet professionnel aussi j'ai passé
un concours des aides médico
psychologiques
j'ai eu les écrits donc bientôt j'ai
passé l'oral et danse à montfranc
crescendo quoi pour renault c'est une
vraie bouée de sauvetage cet emploi du
temps de récup sortie de son rsa et de
la spirale du chômage m'a fait ainsi
appelé le cuisine les cuisiniers de
métier mais bon on n'était pas évident
non plus donc voilà les reins petit peu
dans tous les sens fait appel à ceux de
la soudure savonnerie un
magazine à ce qu'on peut du tour mais
l'inconnue l'association pas de bouche à
oreille
mais après un été difficile pour trouver
du travail donc mal on sent mal dans une
récupération de vêtements qui nécessite
quelques règles pour ne pas compliquer
le processus s'il dit nous les rappelle
ce qui est très important que tous les
réunionnais comprennent bien c'est que
quand ceux-ci déposent quelque chose
dans les bonnes que l'on a dans les
villes dans les déchetteries tous à des
poses propres et secs s'il vous plaît
parce que toutes les matières soulier ou
mouillé ne peut pas traiter ça sur la
plateforme les opérateurs de tri sont
sont exposés à des maladies et ça on
voudrait éviter et il ya que la
population qui peut être à nous dans ce
sens là c'est désormais un rendez vous
qui attire énormément de monde la vente
au kilo une fois le choix des vêtements
chaussures ou sacs effectuer la pesée
permet de définir le montant de la
facture on veut avoir une certaine
rentabilité cette rentabilité pour la
voir c'est que on est obligé de passer
par de la vente des produits donc tout
ce qui est collecté étrillé le meilleur
va être vendue à 4 euros le kilo deux
fois dans le mois à partir du 5 du mois
un vendredi à samedi sur notre zone sea
dogs récup ou à l'avenir en rose puisque
des perspectives de délocalisation et
d'entrepôts plus grands devraient
permettre à cette activité de recyclage
et de protection de l'environnement de
se développer encore plus et créer de
nouveaux emplois